welcome back to age 20 special
relativity in this section we'll talk
about waves um you've all seen waves you
know what a wave is in principle
you might have had an opportunity to
serve in a wave
just like the one behind me
what you want to do here is be more
quantitative and more precise in in the
definitions and also look at different
sorts of waves
i find this wikipedia article here quite
interesting it starts with
saying that in physics a wave is an
oscillation accompanied by the transfer
of energy that travels through space or
mass
it continues then
talking about the various types of waves
and it makes the distinction between
mechanical waves
which travels through medium or
substance
and the deformation is of of the
substance is reversed by restoring force
in contrast
there is
waves which we have just seen in the
previous section
um they do not require a medium and that
is topic of the next sections as we as
they continue the discussion of special
relativity
here the electromagnetic waves consist
of an oscillation of electrical and
magnetic fields
which are generated through charged
particles
um electron since they don't require a
medium they can travel through the
vacuum but an electromagnetic wave can
also travel through a medium
um like water or
anything else you come up with
um it doesn't stop there really because
you know the concepts of weights are
really like everywhere in physics
specifically when you start studying
quantum mechanics the behavior of
particles those are described by waves
and you know
really exciting recent results
are those of the discovery of
gravitational waves which are
vibrations or movement of the
gravitational fields
also zones those don't require a medium
they travel through
vacuum um when we look at waves we can
start characterizing them and and one
primary sort of characterization is the
polarization of a wave meaning whether
or not
there's
the oscillation itself happens in a
transverse way with respect to the
direction of of movement or in the
longitudinal direction of
longitudinal to the direction of
movement
mechanical waves can be transverse and
longitudinal polarizer polarized or have
transverse and longitudinal components
electromagnetic waves in free space are
transverse only
so here's a picture of a wave
sine or cosine um and you know we
can start with the characterization the
one aspect is the amplitude how big is
for example the water wave how big is
the maximum strength of the electric or
magnetic field that's the amplitude
waves propagate
and they have a velocity that is a
characterization
the length of the waves the wavelength
is another way of characterizing
in physics it's always important to
understand the unix units of the objects
we discuss
here just as a reminder the velocity
given in meter per second
the frequency
of your wave so how often do we find a
trough for a wave for example per second
the frequency one over second the
wavelength in meters
we can continue with the
characterization and be a little bit
more complete
we can start from the medium the period
the polarization transfers are
longitudinal the wavelength frequency
velocity or even how much energy is
being carried by the wave
when we compare waves and look at their
properties we have to consider the phase
of the waves so where
do for example two waves line up the
difference in phase between two waves
and some of one some waves can interfere
um so if you have two waves which
interfere
and they're out of phase like the one
drawn in this picture the resulting wave
has amplitude zero this is called
destructive interference you can have
constructive interference for example
when those two waves are aligned there's
no phase difference and then the
amplitudes simply add at
situation can be more complicated
we study the speed of a wave
there's a number of considerations the
first one is that the speed of a wave
depends on the medium in which it
travels
and the study of the
speed or the the velocity
dependence on the medium is
part of what we will discuss
whether or not when in the discussion of
whether or not there is a medium
responsible for carrying electromagnetic
waves
um
the source so you know for
electromagnetic waves you have a charged
particle
does the speed of the source change the
speed of the wave the answer is no
it changes the wavelength or the
frequency but the velocity is not
changed and you find this for example in
sound waves
in the doppler effect when you listen to
a police car you hear that the frequency
changes depending on whether or not the
police car is coming towards you or
driving away from you that's called the
doppler effect that does not change the
velocity of sounds in air
that's independent
um if you're when your medium is moving
that changes the velocity um and so here
you have to add the velocities of the
meter
so for light as a summary
light is an electromagnetic wave which
is moving in vacuum with speed c
and that is independent of the source
okay um but you can ask in which frame
in which frame is that the velocity of
light and what is the medium and that is
really the discussion we want to carry
on from here
at the time when einstein developed
special relativity there was still a
discussion going on whether or not
electromagnetic waves are
of the nature of the particle or of the
nature of a wave and whether or not that
wave
moves in a medium which was called ether
so we can then you know experimentally
determine this we can look at various
properties of our waves and ask whether
or not this is consistent with the
hypothesis that this is a particle this
is a wave in ether maybe both maybe
neither and we can then fill a table
like this one here and now answer the
question so this is again an opportunity
for you to stop the video and think
through this and try to answer
the individual questions
i do this here for you
um
one characteristic of light at least
when there is no heavy masses involved
is that it travels in a straight line
that is certainly consistent with this
light being a particle but it's also
consistent with its being the wave so
the answer is both
um
are correct interference and diffraction
pattern that's rather difficult to
describe for particle model but waves as
we just saw can interfere and there can
be diffraction
polarization
what does it mean for a particle to be
polar polarized um but waves can be
polarized we have just seen transverse
and longitudinal polarization
light velocity depend on the velocity of
this on the source velocity for
particles that doesn't seem to to uh
to hold for waves the stars
and then the last is you know the speed
of light crater and air than in water
that's true for for wave for particles
you know you might argue
this one but i put a no in this table
here
which means that in our discussion up to
this point
clearly
the hypothesis of a wave for light and
ether holes
we'll see
in the next sections that there's
aspects of light where the discussion
will not forward like this especially
for the
ether hypothesis
you